Bernie Sanders proposes a taxpayer
bailout for all student loans in the
United States but what the left won't
admit is that student loan forgiveness
is nothing but welfare for the rich we
will analyze the numbers then Iran keeps
provoking us to war will president Trump
take the bait that crazy lady who's
accusing Trump of rape says more crazy
things on television and the White House
name is a new press secretary who isn't
me that's okay though I'm not I was just
actually cutting some onions before this
it's great great news all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
great news I almost almost couldn't do
the show today but no it's it's okay
it's well analyse who she is a little
bit later she actually does seem to be a
very good candidate for it though a lot
of big shoes to fill after Sarah Sanders
but first support for the Michael
Knowles show comes from our friends at
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans finding
the right house isn't easy but finding
the right mortgage can be loans are in
the news a lot today a lot of
Millennials making a lot of bad
decisions when it comes to their loans
don't be one of them use rocket mortgage
rocket mortgage is doing more to help
you understand the home buying process
so that you can get exactly what you
need because it's not just a mortgage
it's your mortgage and they have found a
better way their team of mortgage
experts is obsessed with finding a
better way which means their number one
goal is to make the home buying process
smoother for you buying a home is a
miserable experience it's very difficult
you got it it's very time-intensive you
got a jump on certain things and adding
on to that getting a mortgage is so
problematic it's so difficult it's so
frustrating rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way they make it so
much better
Quicken Loans has helped millions of
Americans achieve their dream of
homeownership and when you're ready to
purchase the home of your dreams they
can help you too when you work with them
you get more than just alone because
rocket mortgage is more than just a
lender get started online at rocket
mortgage comm slash Knolls kano wles
Equal Housing lender license for all 50
states nmls consumer accessed at organ
number 30 30 rocket mortgage by Quicken
Loans push button get mortgage we're
gonna be talking about loans a whole lot
today because Bernie Sanders has a new
plan to cancel all of the student loan
debt in the country not just some of it
not just for people who can't pay it not
just for poor people not just for people
who don't get a job one point six
trillion dollars of student loans
currently owed by 45 million people 40
million of whom are college graduates
that 40 41 million who are college
graduates about 4 million of whom are
dropouts so they're really having
trouble paying their loans this is the
most radical proposal we've seen yet and
they've all been talking about this for
a while the Democrat
candidates have been building up to this
so previously Bernie had proposed making
community colleges and four-year public
colleges tuition free for people who
make less than one hundred twenty five
thousand dollars per year so that's a
lot of money you know 20 125 grand that
would cover a lot of people still not
nearly as radical as this Elizabeth
Warren had taken it a step further and
talked about forgiving student loan debt
what her proposal would have done was
giving all Americans who have student
loans up to 50 grand
even that is nowhere near what we're
seeing now from Bernie Sanders some
people have student loans upwards of
$200,000 or more Harris Booker
Gillibrand all the Senate Democrats
running for president they endorse
something called the debt free college
act still not even close to this this
would wipe out all of the student loan
debt currently owed in the country would
do nothing for the people who already
paid off their student loans ostensibly
wouldn't do anything for the people who
are about to take out student loans for
the people who currently have them it
would wipe them away Democrats love this
idea here's aoc embracing it at a her
own press conference because the Sun
can't rise in the morning without AOC
holding a press conference and she is
totally owning this issue I will be
completely honest I will disclose my my
personal stake in this fight because I
have student loans too
and I think it's so funny a year ago I
was waiting tables in a restaurant and
it was literally easier for me to become
the youngest woman in American history
elected to Congress than it is to pay
off my student loan debt so that should
tell you everything about the state of
this of this of our economy and the
state of quality of life for working
people it doesn't it doesn't tell you
about the state of our economy or the
state of the quality of life of working
people it tells you about the state of
education of education nationally and
specifically about AOC education
she got a very expensive education she
went to a college called Boston
University it's a private college it
costs today about seventy thousand per
year seventy thousand dollars per year
to go there and that education wasn't
worth it
I'm not saying Boston University is
never worth it I'm saying
AOC didn't get a whole lot out of it
it's funny she majored in economics she
knows nothing about economics but if she
went there hoping that it would help get
her a job she took out $200,000 I don't
know how much she took out in student
loans but she could have taken up a two
hundred thousand dollars she did not
learn enough in that university to pay
it off with the job she got after
college because the job she got after
college she says she was waiting tables
she was a bartender so either because of
what she studied or how she applied it
or what she learned from it
her education did not translate into
lots of money afterward now being a
bartender is a fine job some of my
favorite people are bartenders but it's
it's not a fine job if you've got
$200,000 in student debt you don't need
to go to college to be a bartender
you're not really supposed to get a
liberal education to get a job anyway
the purpose of a liberal education is
education for itself you only study
things like literature history
mathematics things that don't have
direct applicability it's not pre
professional training it's it's the arts
of Liberty it's the arts to understand
your liberty and to understand your role
as a free citizen and to understand your
own civilization so it's fine to be a
bartender but if you're saddling
yourself with $200,000 of debt and you
think that that's gonna get you a very
high-paying job afterward then being a
bartender isn't gonna cut it
now she says it's it's so crazy she did
something so much harder she became the
youngest woman ever elected to Congress
that's so much harder than being a
bartender no it isn't no it isn't being
a bartender is much harder than being a
congressman it requires much more in in
terms of social intelligence it requires
probably requires a higher IQ the job of
being a congressman offers an inflated
salary and much higher future earnings
potential for mediocrities most people
who are in Congress are not terribly
intelligent they're not terribly serious
people they're just glad handing
grifters who make a bunch of money on
taxpayer dollar
and then they leave and they become
lobbyists and they make even more money
there are some good people in Congress I
have some friends in Congress I like Dan
Crenshaw that he's a terrific guy
super smart loves this country most
people in Congress are not Dan Crenshaw
so I'm not at all surprised AOC
graduates college he hasn't learned
anything she's saddled herself with debt
for what is basically a worthless degree
and she realizes gosh in the private
sector I'm never gonna make anything I'm
not gonna make any money out here and
I'm gonna just be waiting tables or
being a bartender for the rest of my
life and never be able to pay off this
debt but I can run for Congress this is
the path forward for mediocrities
coast-to-coast this is a very ironic
proposal though because what the left
doesn't want to admit is that student
loan forgiveness is not a way to help
out poor people it's not a way to help
out the oppressed underclass student
loan forgiveness is welfare for the rich
as always it's the left pretending that
they're sticking up for the little guy
when really they are sticking up for the
elites Bernie and AOC say this is going
to help the average the working American
the average working American doesn't
have a college degree one-third of
Americans graduate from college
two-thirds of Americans don't graduate
from college Americans who do graduate
from college statistically speaking can
expect to make a lot more money
the median American college graduate
makes about 75 percent more per year
than the average American who only has
high school diploma okay that's you you
do get a pay off if you go to college
statistically speaking the median person
who goes to college is going to make
significantly more money that comes with
a cost you have to pay the tuition you
have to pay off your student loans it's
not as though Bernie Sanders in a OCR
like paying off these people's student
loans out of charity the taxpayers are
paying so you now have a system being
proposed by Bernie and AOC where the
majority of Americans who make
comparatively less money than college
graduates will be paying off the
reckless financial decisions will be
bailing out the minority of Americans
who choose to go to college and get that
education who will statistically make
significantly more money than the
majority over the course of their lives
this is a bailout from the comparatively
poor to the comparatively rich now the
leftist is trying to avoid this
criticism Bernie has not acknowledged
aoc has not acknowledged it Ilhan Omar
to her credit has sort of alluded to
this issue that it's it's the minority
of people who were going to college in
the first place who are graduating from
college it's people who have much higher
future earnings potential and people who
don't go to college why is the rest of
America going to bail them out for
something that's going to make them more
money in the long run ilan omar sort of
alludes to this generation many of them
played by the rules follow the advice of
our parents our leaders and got an
education
we are told going to college opens a
world of opportunity but far too many
it's accompanied by a world of anxiety
stress and never-ending that we are told
by some politicians that this debt is
our fault
that if we want to achieve the American
dream we have to lift ourselves up by
our bootstraps well we're here today to
say student debt it's not the result of
pad choices or behavior it is the result
of a system that tells the students to
get an education and go to college in
order to have a stable life but then
does not provide the resources to afford
that education you see that they're not
the elites they're not the ones who are
gonna make more money they're the
victims they were tricked into it by
their parents by society they're their
victims they have this debt it's not
their choices it's not their benefit
it's not their future likely elite
lifestyle no no they're the real victims
and the majority of Americans who don't
have a college degree who they're now
telling to bail out the minority who
will they they're it's incumbent on them
because they haven't had such awful
oppression as the people who spend four
years at very expensive private colleges
totally outrageous speaking of making
money
big tech companies make gobs and gobs of
money because you and I give all of them
our data and if you want to keep giving
them your data that's fine there's no
big deal but here's what I recommend you
should make a little money on that too
and you can do that finally with big
token this is so great here's how it
works
big token is this easy to download app
you sign up for it you get a free big
token account then you complete actions
to get points so that that can be
answering surveys you can check into
locations just say okay I'm here click
it then you get some points you connect
your social media accounts you get some
points all of these sort of things
then you redeem those points for rewards
like cash and gift cards or you can
donate your earnings to charity if
you're a good person but you know
probably you're you're just going to
take the cash you choose what data you
share with big token then you get paid
for it so your data are always secured
with big token and the best part is you
get paid the thing I really love about
this is we're not trying to fight
reality we're not going to say no one's
ever gonna get my data no-one's ever
again I'm gonna find any of my data on
the Internet
that's a fool's errand that's never
gonna happen so what you can do is
understanding reality make a little
money off of it so it's not just them
making money you're gonna make a little
money too if you want to start earning
money for your data go to the App Store
or Google Play search for big token
b.i.g Tok en that's one word download
the app and sign up most important use
my referral code Knolls KO wles because
then i'll make money too and keep this
show on the air which is very important
because i'm not going to be the next
White House press secretary search big
token in the App Store or Google Play
download the app use my referral code
Knowles Kanter wles to sign up claim
your data and get paid Elan Homar does
not want to take responsibility for her
financial decisions so she's blaming
everybody she's saying yeah obviously
this is the sort of basic aspect of
leftism she's blaming people for her
problems right my parents made me go to
college my society made me go to college
made me go to college not me the loan
companies tricked me into taking out
loans and go whatever the other aspect
of leftism here is they want to get
something with no cost and with no risk
it's true you can take out a hundred
thousand dollars in loans go to college
graduate not having learned anything not
having studied very hard not
having been appropriate for college
maybe there was a better path for you
but you did go to college now you got a
lot of debt you're not making a lot of
money that's risk life involves risk you
don't you don't have perfect security
little babies have perfect security and
even little babies frankly don't have a
perfect security certainly grown adults
tone you've got to take some
responsibility and there's cost so for
the median and everyone else you're
gonna make a lot of money after you
graduate from college that doesn't just
come for free not just because you're so
pretty not just because you're so
privileged and wonderful and beautiful
people are going to give this to you for
free you incur that cost and then you
get a reward for that in the long run
according to a new survey just came out
2/3 of employees in America are
reporting having regrets when it comes
to their degrees they wish they didn't
get it according to a pay scale survey
of about 250 thousand respondents this
past spring they have regrets because I
don't think they have regrets because
they don't want to make the extra money
which statistically they are they are
making significantly more money than if
they hadn't gone to college they regret
that they have to pay for it sorry buddy
there's no such thing as a free lunch if
you want something in this life you've
got to pay for it so the other question
on this is why are we only going to pay
off student loans if the if the minority
of people are the ones who are getting
the student loans why are we privileged
annette also are we gonna reimburse
people who already paid off their loans
or are we going to give a bonus to
people who were able to get scholarships
to college so they didn't need as much
in student loans or any student loans
are we going to give anything to the
majority of Americans who don't have
student loans why not car forgiveness
why not car loan forgiveness the average
car payment in America is significantly
higher than the average student loan
payment and way more people have car
payments than have student loan payments
why are we gonna bet mortgage payments
are we gonna do that now that the left
would say this is the Democrat response
they say College helps the economy sort
of a common good because you're more
educated people you have the more
they're going to make a lot of money and
that wealth is going to trickle down
ironically they're making a sort of
trickle-down argument from the left say
it's great it's a common good there's
gonna be more businesses
it's helpful to the community when
people get educated okay car ownership
helps the economy - car ownership helps
the economy way more than most college
degrees car driving also should be
encouraged by society it's how people
get to work it's how people pick up the
kids from school that's how they keep
the economy moving if we pay off student
debt why aren't we gonna pay off car
loan debt if we pay off student and car
loan debt why are we gonna pay off
mortgage debt people need a place to
live don't they people need a place to
live way more than they need to study
lesbian dance therapy at Palookaville
University don't they if we're gonna pay
off all those debts certainly we should
pay off homeowner debt now what is debt
people also don't know what debt is why
do people have debt people have debt
because they are borrowing against their
future earnings you need some money
today the money today is more valuable
than waiting and having the money in 20
years so you're gonna pay a little bit
of an interest rate on that because
there's a time value of money and you're
gonna use that money now it's gonna help
you it's gonna propel you ideally and
that's how modern economies work if you
know that you're gonna make 75 percent
more per year by going to college then
you're definitely going to borrow the
money now because you're gonna have 60
years of earning all that more money
you're gonna pay it off it's gonna be a
good deal that allows for economic
growth but if there's never any
consequence to debt then the system of
credit is gonna collapse because no
one's gonna have faith in the system
right the way that credit works is you
have to have people believe that there's
gonna be a consequence to not paying it
off otherwise why would anyone pay off
their debts if we forgive 1.6 trillion
in student loan debt why would anyone
ever again make a student loan payment
it actually wouldn't be fair for them to
do it it already wouldn't be fair for
the people who paid off their debt so
why would they ever make that pit we're
just gonna have to bail out student
loans all the time if we forgive all the
student loans we are creating a federal
entitlement to free college and free
private college for that matter but once
the government gets involved I guess it
becomes a public college no one will pay
off their debts
the big question politicians need to
solve here is not why but not all of the
oppression not all of the victimhood not
all the terrible reasons why people want
to
College they need to figure out why is
college so expensive why is it because
the federal government guarantees loans
so it's an that's a blank check to
colleges to raise their tuition which is
skyrocketed over the last 2025 years
why else because more students are going
so you're flooding the market you're
telling people they need to get a
college degree and so the colleges have
the opportunity to just raise the prices
in 2016 nearly 70 percent of high school
graduates enrolled in college a lot of
those people are not going to graduate
for a lot of them it was a terrible idea
to enroll in college very expensive
mistake but 70 percent almost in the
1940s do you know how many people got a
college degree 5 percent 4 or 5 percent
even in the 1950s 5 6 percent of people
so now we got 70 percent of people going
to college back in the 40s and 50s we
had like 5 percent do we really think
that people today are much better
educated than our grandparents were no
of course not if anything we're less
educated today we have more degrees were
more credentialed but we're less
educated in the 1950s universities
required knowledge of Latin as a
prerequisite do you know Latin has your
Latin not great has my Latin terrible
high schools taught Latin because of
this requirement today
even top universities don't require
Latin some universities don't even offer
Latin in the 1950s education made sense
I mean getting a good education always
makes sense but I'm saying the education
that was being offered actually was
coherent it was based around a common
curriculum was based around the Western
Canon it's based around our civilization
so you'd read the ancients through the
Middle Ages through modernity you would
understand how Aristotle and Homer
relate to lucid --'tis relate to the
Bible relate to Dante then relate to
Boccaccio relate to Shakespeare then how
all of those people relate to the
moderns how they relate to Thomas
Aquinas so Thomas Aquinas takes
Aristotle he makes him Christian and
you get to Machiavelli and modernity
then you get to Hobbes and Rousseau and
TS Eliot and it makes sense you have a
picture of how ideas have progressed how
we got to where we are it used to make
sense in and of itself now it doesn't
now you just pick random subjects okay
I'm going to take modern French film and
I'm going to take math for English
majors and that's supposed to be an
education but it's not and that's what
almost everyone has now education always
so used to make sense for students so if
you want it in a lead education you've
got a liberal education if you want it
to be an electrician you apprenticed
under an electrician or you got a trade
education if you wanted to be an
entrepreneur sometimes you got a liberal
education sometimes you didn't get any
education you just started building
things you just started doing stuff
right out of high school if you even
finished high school now education
doesn't make sense for students the
problem is not that the cost is too high
or that people have too much debt or
that that it's too hard to get in or
whatever the problem is that we have
devalued education by saying that
everyone needs to go and that the
government will basically create an
entitlement to it we have devalued it
okay I personally I paid very little for
college because I got a lot of
scholarships and I actually know who
gave my know the guy who had the name
scholarship who then I received his
scholarship I got to meet him I went to
the Opera with him great guy that
creates a feeling of gratitude that
creates a debt I understand that even
though I didn't have to pay a lot for
college barely had to pay anything I
know that it wasn't free somebody worked
very hard to allow me to go that create
some responsibilities if the government
is just gonna forgive all the debts
there's no feeling of gratitude that's
just a that creates an entitlement it
creates a feeling of entitlement of all
of these AOC and Ilhan Omar these bratty
little girls who are saying I want
something for free why and where it's
not my fault that I have to pay
something for the great benefits that
I've had that's what it creates free
college only exacerbates the problem we
need to make it clear once again that
not everyone needs the same schooling
because when everybody has the same
government-run schooling then you have a
lot of schooling you don't have a whole
lot of education unfortunately the
problem seems to be
worse and you see that lack of education
every time a OC opens our mouth moving
on from the 2020 race we have to talk
about war because Iran keeps threatening
us with war and this is creating a lot
of consternation in the White House and
on the right especially so what is Iran
doing Iran looks like they set a few oil
tank couple oil tankers on fire last
week
looks like they shot a missile at one
they also then shot down our 130 million
dollar drone which is very frustrating
no Americans killed but 130 million
dollars a lot of money so the question
is are we going to war with Iran it
looked like the United States was going
to launch some strikes on Iranian
targets and President Trump called it
off at the last minute according to
White House reports which he alluded to
why did he say he doesn't want to go to
war why did he call off the strikes
because he said it's not worth killing
people for a drone which is an amazing
statement from the president they call
this guy Hitler they call him an
authoritarian war monger he's like the
most peaceful president I've ever seen
certainly in my lifetime
they call him bloodthirsty I think he's
certainly the most peaceful president
since Ronald Reagan he heard that it
would about 150 people would be killed
in Iran if if they struck those targets
and he said no I'm not gonna do that for
a drum not gonna kill those people it's
not their fault you know Barack Obama
loved invading Muslim countries they
said they said if I voted for John
McCain then we'd go to war with another
Muslim country and obviously that was
correct because I voted for McCain and
we went to war with more Muslim
countries George W Bush responded to
9/11 by invading Afghanistan and Iraq
Bill Clinton bombed a medicine factory
in Sudan just to get Lewinsky out of the
news that's how little it took for Bill
Clinton to go to war Bush 41 obviously
led the gulf war Ronald Reagan actually
was also fairly double he didn't really
like going to war very much a lot of
similarities with Trump or Ronald Reagan
sent forces into Lebanon and then you
had the Beirut bombing and over 200
Americans were killed and he pulled
those forces out pretty quick so what
does president Trump gonna do his
supporters don't want to go to war with
Iran generally but there is sort of a
split here there's a split in the
conservative mind on this
on the one hand we say Iran is awful
they're terrible they're a terrible
government they're ruining a world order
I don't care about them at all blow up
the whole country that's one idea the
other one is I don't care about Iran I
don't care about Iran at all I don't
want to send American soldiers to fight
because it doesn't seem to really affect
me that's the other idea they're both
kind of views of going to war that have
a kind of machismo to them their boat
they have a conservatism to them but
we're debating now which one to do what
does president Trump gonna do he finally
made his announcement yesterday
sanctions imposed through the executive
order that I'm about to sign will deny
the Supreme Leader and the Supreme
Leader's office and those closely
affiliated with him and the office
access to key financial resources and
support the assets of Ayatollah Khomeini
and his office will not be spared from
the sanctions okay so I have to stop it
right there because the left was
attacking Trump yesterday they were all
making fun of him because he referred to
the Ayatollah Khomeini who died in 1989
what a total idiot
can't you what a what a nincompoop he
talked about Ayatollah Khomeini like
Ayatollah Khomeini is still alive so I
asked a few of these people on Twitter I
said okay yeah Ayatollah Khomeini is
dead what's the new guy's name none of
them knew because they don't know
anything they make these jokes like
guffawing buffoons but they don't they
don't know the punchline the new guys
name is Ayatollah Khamenei okay so he
mispronounced the name it's pretty close
it's not like he he he confused him with
John Smith or something it's Khomeini
and Khamenei give me a break he's
reading on the paper he doesn't know no
it's not it's not like the biggest deal
in the world he goes on to the actual
meat of what he's talking about
these measures represent a strong and
proportionate response to Iran's
increasingly provocative actions we will
continue to increase pressure on terror
until the regime abandons its dangerous
activities and his aspirations including
the pursuit of nuclear weapons increased
enrichment of uranium
development of ballistic missiles
engagement in and support for terrorism
fueling of foreign conflicts and
belligerent acts directed against the
United States and its allies okay
so he's talking tough he's getting tough
as a diplomatic measure but he isn't
saying the bombs are gonna fly in five
minutes what is going on
with Iran the friend of the show foreign
policy expert Mike Duran has an
interesting take on this we'll get to in
a second then we'll get to that crazy
lady who's accusing Trump of rape and a
whole lot more but first I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube go over
to daily wire comm ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
you at the end of clayvin show you at
the ben shapiro show you get them at
wall show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag which is coming up on
Thursday get them in you get to ask
questions backstage you get the leftist
here's tumblr mmm oh yes that's very
good yeah that sounds like it sounds
like we're not going to forgive your 1.6
trillion dollars in loans if they think
that payout payouts 1.6 trillion dollar
payouts for the minority of Americans
who are these elite effete generally
left wingers that's gonna rally people
to go vote for them in 2020 probably not
a great look head over to Daly wire.com
we'll be back with a lot more
okay what's Iran really up to Mike Duran
one of my go-to guys when it comes to
especially Iran policy he has a piece
out at mosaic magazine and it's the most
coherent and compelling argument I've
heard yet the title of the article is
what Iran is really up to and then the
byline or the the sub header is
desperate to preserve the nuclear deal
Iran with the help of its Western
friends is creating just enough turmoil
to make America and not it appear eager
for war and that seems to be about right
so what's going on all of the American
allies in Europe and the g20 nations
they're all fearful we're told because
Donald Trump is a populist and he's
upsetting the established order of
decaying liberalism they're afraid in
Europe they're afraid of their own
right-wing populism and so specifically
on the Europeans Khamenei wants to scare
them about the threat of war with Iran
and they want to to scare them about the
threat to the international order and
then this is what Mike Duran thinks
they're going to offer a multilateral
diplomatic way to avoid that war and you
know what that way is
it's the Iran deal the Iran deal had
President Trump campaigned against and
ripped up when he got into office so it
turns out we never fully pulled out of
the Iran deal we ripped up most of it
but we crucially are still issuing
waivers to our European allies to allow
them to cooperate with Iran on certain
projects that are permitted under the
deal so we didn't totally pull out of it
and what this means is it actually does
give us a little bit of leverage so one
of the arguments against pulling out of
the Iran deal is it takes away our
leverage we actually still have a little
bit of leverage President Trump could
reinstate all sanctions every punishment
against Iran with the snap of his
fingers he could completely end the Iran
deal and this is the worst case scenario
for Iran
so what Iran wants to do is present
President Trump as the enemy of a
rules-based international order this is
very high Larry
because Iran since the Iranian
Revolution has been the chief
international opponent of the
international order they're worse than
North Korea in this regard because at
least North Korea doesn't pretend to be
a part of the international order and
system Iran does Iran puts one foot in
the international order they show up and
they give their speeches at Columbia
University and the UN and they they wear
suits and ties or whatever version of
that they wear they try to pretend to be
serious participants in the
international world order then they fund
terrorism all around the world there the
chief exporter of terrorism they
undermine the international order left
and right one foot in one foot out so
Iran announces in keeping with how they
behave they announced on June 17th that
their nuclear stockpiles are about to
exceed the limit of the Iran deal but
the Iran deal is over right now why did
they announce that on June 17th but just
in time for the g20 summit right around
the corner so Mike Duran writes quote
Iran's policy of strategic pressure then
is made up of three separate but
interlocking lines of effort a struggle
to gain relief from the oil and banking
sanctions a campaign to tarnish Trump as
an agent of chaos and an initiative
aimed at keeping its nuclear waivers in
place among these the third is by far
the most urgent to understand why we
need to examine the function of the
waivers and why they are exceptionally
valuable to Ali Khamenei so this is all
about the Iran deal all about getting
those waivers to keep building up their
nuclear program
so Shinzo Abe a the Japanese leader kate
went over to iran this past month and
right around the time he was there iran
blew up a partially japanese owned oil
tanker they said this doesn't make any
sense they're trying to threaten
everyone else and scare them about
president Trump's role in the
international order so according to
reports President Trump sent a message
with Shinzo Abe a for Ayatollah Khamenei
and Khamenei responded to obey and said
I have no message for Trump I have no
message at all I'm not going to dignify
him with a response but of course he's
sending a message to Trump
a message with missiles he's trying to
get and more importantly sending a
message to Europe what does this show us
it shows us one Obama got bungled Iran
completely Obama assumed wrongly that he
could diplomatically stop Iran from
getting a nuclear weapon can't be done
that is not going to happen ever and
Obama tried it and it didn't work and
other people have tried it too you can
only stop Iran from getting a nuclear
weapon
with force that's the hard reality now
as as Mike Duran says that's not doesn't
necessarily mean war though it very
possibly could mean war but ultimately
you will need coercion
you will need coercive measures that are
not just people singing Kumbaya
ironically what what does this mean an
eternal rule of statecraft
is that if you want to avoid war you
need to be totally ready to go to war if
you want to avoid war you need to be
able to credibly threaten going to war
and that is the line that President
Trump is walking now so people are
saying sending mixed messages he is an
anti-war candidate and John Bolton is
his national security adviser John
Bolton has been in Iran hawkers entire
life on the one hand he says I don't
want war on the other hand there's a
military operation in place to strike
Iran but then he calls it off what is
happening he's trying to show that we
have the credible threat of force and we
will do it he's actually using against
Iran the very thing that Iran is trying
to use against America which is the
president Trump is a madman you can't
predict what he's going to do I
genuinely can't predict what he's gonna
do on Iran neither can come in it so
what Trump is saying is you can't
predict what I'm gonna do
cut it out and don't make a nuclear
weapon because we will go to war we will
force you not to have that nuclear
weapon
what Khamenei is saying is look at that
madman over in America we need the Iran
nuclear deal we need we need to force
America back into this deal because he's
a madman he'll blow up the whole world
order
that's the standoff right now it's it's
over the question of how mad is Donald
Trump and which side is he going to come
down on when that charade is over
I have no prediction
because his strategy is working speaking
of mad people and crazy people a couple
days ago you you know there was a few
days ago now there was that woman II
Jean Carol the New York advice columnist
who accused Trump of raping her 23 years
ago in Bergdorf Goodman dressing room
and we saw that interview that she did
with Allison Cammarata and it was really
weird and it wasn't terribly credible
and the story was falling apart so she
did another interview she did an
interview on MSNBC and she was
discussing what she should have done in
that moment what was going through her
mind what she could have changed about
that moment you know not going in not
being raped by Donald Trump not coming
out with this before 23 years later do
you know what she says she would have
done if she could change anything about
the event while Donald Trump was in the
room with her bad to raper
she would have asked for his tax returns
so I just Lawrence I wish I had said I
wish I said I'll tell you my age if you
show me your tax returns okay all right
well that's a little odd isn't it so she
has these lines she keeps evading the
question and saying all these crazy
things she then says it wasn't rape so
she's saying but before she was calling
the referring to this is rape and this
was her rape in there now she's avoided
those direct questions when she's done
these interviews now she's saying it
wasn't rape and she explains why it
wasn't rape in an interview on CNN with
Anderson Cooper it did not last long and
that's why I don't use the word you just
used I use the word fight you don't use
the word rape sexual violence is in
every country in every strata of society
and I just feel that so many women are
undergoing sexual violence and mine was
short I got out I'm happy now I'm moving
on
and I think of all the women who are
enduring
constant sexual violence so this one
instant this one what three minutes in
this little dressing room I just say
it's a
fight that way I'm not the victim okay
hold it there for just a second she says
she's not using the word rape because
she doesn't want to offend
less-fortunate women who were raped that
doesn't make any sense
just because you are relatively better
off than someone else doesn't mean that
a crime can't be committed against you
when a rich guy gets burglarized
he doesn't refuse to call the police or
say he wasn't burglarized because poor
people are also burglarized so when
women experience rape but there are sort
of relatively wealthier or better known
or better-off it's still rape it's not
not rape because some poor woman also
can be raped
now the reason she's not trying not to
use the term rape I suspect is because
she wasn't raped by Donald Trump because
her story's completely falling apart but
the interview then takes the craziest
turn of all when she tells people when
she tells Anderson Cooper though another
reason that she won't refer to the the
event that took place as rape is because
rape is sexy you don't feel like a
victim
I was not throwing on the ground and
ravish which the word rape carries so
many sexual connotations this was not
this was not sexual but just it hurt it
just what it just you know I think most
people think of rape as a I mean it is a
violent assault it is not I think most
people think of rape as being sexy let's
take a short break of the fantasies
we've gotta take a quick break if you
can stick around we'll talk more on the
other side you're fascinating to talk to
oh man that does not look great we'll
take a quick break please please cut the
cameras so now this woman has no
credibility the left is saying we'll
forget about her but think of all the
other women who have accused Trump we're
told a lot of women have accused Trump I
haven't seen a lot of them but they were
told that all these women accused Trump
of rape even on the right even David
French said this he said look when this
first came out and he believed her
before he saw the video I suspect he
said look at this
we have to come to grips with the fact
that President Trump is very likely a
rapist no we don't well they're credible
accusations or their credit are they
credible is that woman credible if all
the women are as credible as that woman
then none of the accusations are
credible at all then there's no reason
to believe them this is the same line
the left always uses they say well you
know forget about this particular claim
you know whenever they're they're
hysterical claims get disproven by the
facts they say well forget about this
one instance that okay maybe that one
wasn't true but it gets to a greater
truth okay if it gets to a greater truth
show me the actual examples of it well
no we can't show you these but just know
a five million women accused Trump of
rape so look one of them has to be right
right one of them has to be telling the
truth no they could all be lying or you
could actually more likely you could be
lying even in your presentation of that
narrative this this woman is the most
prolific astronomer for to come out and
accuse president Trump of raping her her
story has no credibility now this is
about the narrative this is about the
left pushing the one their narrative and
us trying to refute it with facts we
have a new person who's going to be
doing that from the White House
unfortunately it's not going to be me
it's okay I'm not crying no big deal I'm
not crying milania's spokesman Stephanie
Grisham is gonna be the new White House
press secretary this news just broke
about an hour ago we don't know a ton
about her you know she she works for a
lot of Arizona politicians worked on the
Romney campaign's coordinated press for
the Pope's visit to Philly and she was a
press aide to the Trump campaign she has
a great reputation doesn't seem to have
a lot of dirt on her the one claim there
they're throwing at her is that she
violated the Hatch Act which prevents
people in government from from using
their government offices for political
and campaign purposes and the one
violation they say she made us use the
phrase make America great again
from her official account okay I guess
you're not allowed to say make America
great again now if you work for the
government tells you a lot about our
government she seems pretty good seems
like a solid candidate it's most
thankless job in DC a very big shoes to
fill after Sarah Sanders who was just
terrific in that role I just mentioned
this and I give my condolences to her
for getting the toughest job in DC
because we are battling right now the
battle that we're in is a battle of
language and the press secretary plays a
tremendous role in this you know
actually bringing it all together
getting back to school the issue of
Education College in high school there
was an amazing exchange in Scotland just
happened that highlights this battle of
language that we're in there was a
student who was kicked out of class
because he said that there are only two
genders there are only two sexes and his
teacher said no there are more than two
sexes and the kids said no they're not
you can't that that isn't true and you
can't make me say that something that's
not true
is true he got kicked out of class for
it then he secretly recorded his
conversation with the teacher who was
yelling at him for it this tells you
everything you need to know you all the
way in Scotland tells you everything you
need to know about what's coming this
way in the United States if we don't
stop it around then why would you kick
male class it's not very inclusive or
connected in a sentence please not very
inclusive no I'm sorry but you were
saying was not very inclusive and this
is an inclusive school yeah what house
biasing is everything that the home
website agenda is my opinion
and that is an opinion which is
acceptable in the school
I'm afraid yours which you have seen
that there's no such thing as anyone
other than male or female it's I'm
familiar just two genders depending on
what I get I guess then you are choosing
to make an issue of this because I said
are you really going to you that was
your opportunity just to keep quiet
you made the issues that on the website
you said all this website doesn't have
more than money you were clearly given
an opportunity not to pursue it you
choose to do so yeah because I think
it's you chose to do so yes that's the
key question you chose to do so I think
it's silly to have anything other than
two genders so that okay anything else
please keep that opinion - you're going
house thank you no so you get to put
your opinion out in classroom I know I
am NOT my minion house of states I'm not
putting my opinion I'm not putting my
opinion out I am stating what is
national school Authority policy okay
not scientific whatsoever not every
policy is scientific blank it's sorry
not every side not every policy is
scientific muddy not every policy is
scientific Marie when you've got to
choose between scientific reality and
political politically correct
ideological dogma Marie you've got to
pick the politically correct ideological
dogma forget reality I mean this is what
George war will predicted said there
will be no true or false there will be
no history there will be no facts there
will just be the eternal present where
whatever the party says is right Marie
the party says that 2+2 doesn't equal 4
so 2 plus 2 does not equal 4 keep your
opinion to yourself you hear what he
said to him he said you had the
opportunity to keep quiet and the kid
says right but you're telling me that
there's more than two sexes I know there
aren't so I just said there are two
sexes he says you make you brought this
on yourself Marie it's not that we tried
to teach you something that is obviously
not true you brought it on yourself
because you could have shut up you had
the opportunity to shut up and because
you didn't shut up you brought your own
punishment on yourself you were able not
to pursue this but you pursued the truth
and now we're going to punish you he
says keep your own opinion to your own
house I almost feel bad for this teacher
I mean not really because he's he is the
instrument of the most obvious example
of tyranny that I've seen in modern
politics he is the instrument of that
but he says you keep your opinion about
reality in your own house so I have to
keep my I have to I can't state basic
facts in a school it's like that scene
out of dr. Strangelove there's no
fighting here gentlemen this is the war
room there is no education here Murray
this is a schoolhouse and so the kid
says well it just seems crazy that to
say there's more than two sexes when
there aren't well that's your opinion
keep your opinion in your house and the
kid says well you're going to
me your opinion and he says the most
telling thing he says that's not
necessarily my opinion but that is what
the authorities have told us to say he
says well what the authorities have told
you to say isn't true
he uses the word scientific but the word
science just means knowledge as it isn't
true knowledge it isn't true and the
teacher says policy isn't always
scientific it isn't always true and
you'll go along with it we will use the
coercive power of the state to make you
believe lies and state lies and if you
ever say the truth we're gonna use the
power of the state to punish you now the
Democratic Party in the left wants a
full government takeover of our
education system the government big
enough to give you everything you want
is big enough to take away everything
you have they call it loan forgiveness
we're going to forgive your loans that
means that they are going to control 100
percent the education system in this
country not just the public universities
the private ones too the mechanism by
which students go to these universities
the the money the payment is now going
to be controlled by the government and I
wonder what that education system is
going to look like I wonder if that's
gonna help the education system or if
it's gonna hurt it something tells me
it's gonna look a lot like this
classroom that's our show come back
tomorrow for a lot more in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka watts and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show Joe Biden comes under
attack again bernie offers free college
and pete Budaj edges following apart
that's today on the Ben Shapiro show